aaron rodgers inspired me within the
last hour or so okay
aaron rodgers went on pat mcafee show
and here's the money quote that came
from aaron rodgers on pat mcafee show
aaron rodgers said i sometimes laugh
when people talk about down years for me
because a lot of times down years for me
are career years for most quarterbacks
and i'm like you know what hell yeah i'm
like you know what that's what i got to
remember sometimes
sometimes you just got to be reminded of
who you are so all of that stuff i just
said was really just to get to this
point my worst days are better than most
people's best days so i'm back baby i'm
good i'm over yesterday
i did well i needed to i needed to i
needed to kind of flex like aaron did
last night granted it was atlanta so
four touchdowns against atlanta is you
know practice for most people especially
with their decimated secondary but i
kind of just i needed to hear that i'm
like you know what aaron you're right
man off days for michael smith i went
third person on you just now off days
and smith
are better than most people's best days
so
thank you aaron rodgers another reason i
wanted to start with aaron rodgers is i
just want to remind you michael holla
because i kind of i don't know maybe
it's just my imagination maybe i was
being too sensitive maybe i was yeah
sometimes you know we have communication
issues our audio drops from for crying
out loud from zombies it does so i was
like wait a second
am am i mishearing
or misunderstanding michael holland
because it feels like in the handful of
conversations we've had over the first
few weeks of the season about best
quarterbacks in the league now
feels like you've been dismissing 12 a
little bit just a little bit just feels
like it's been for you it's been mahomes
and russell wilson and that's it feels
like 12 he of the 13 touchdowns and no
picks through four games you'd be kind
of like hey you know aaron rodgers you
know yesterday's news am i
misunderstanding yours that how you felt
so far
before we get there i just want to point
out
that yesterday it sounds like you were
feeling
like i'm aaron rodgers
having a brian hoyer experience is is
that is that really what it was i'm
aaron rodgers
that's who i am
but i got brian i got too much brian
hoyer in my spirit
that's that's extreme i would okay
you couldn't sleep
you said you couldn't sleep
because my standards are so high not
because i can't be landing
with your sleep
well listen uh some of us take it
seriously you know maybe two years
you've been sleeping on aaron rodgers
this season and how great he still is
and he still belongs in the conversation
about best quarterback in the league now
not just up on time but still right now
at 36 years old
all right you always say this i'm gonna
use your own
words against you and we gotta narrow
this thing down we got to narrow this
down because
it's just too wide it's too wide this
conversation just keeps going
every every great performance
that's right you said yeah top five it's
got to be five everybody can't be in the
top five everybody can't believe
everybody everybody can't be mvp yeah
absolutely so so one day it's like hey
have we slept on russell wilson russell
i'm getting my magic i'm getting my
magic johnson on right now i'm getting
my madison johnson all right now i'm
naming that hey what about josh allen
you know
everybody i'm gonna tell you somebody
else who should get in a minute wait
real quick here's a tease i'm gonna tell
you somebody else who should get some
mvp votes but i'm not gonna tell you
that just yet i'm gonna tell you a
minute but continue i'm sure
so we got hey lamar jackson quickest to
five thousand yards passing and two
thousand rupees
patrick mahomes got to be in there bill
o'brien's gone sean watson's gotta be in
there like hey don't forget tom brady
touchdown pastor yeah look
what i'm saying is he's great
but let's not go crazy and say well he
is the best of uh the best quarterback
right now in the league i don't believe
it's the best quarterback in the league
i think he's fantastic he's had a
dynamic career and i'll even go so far
as to say
he is the best packers quarterback of
all time and that's saying a lot because
you know brett favre was there doing
some things and
go old school bar start whatever it is i
can't say
i can't say that
he's the best quarterback in football
right now i don't believe that
you know what
aaron rodgers is to the nfl
what lebron james is to the nba
in so far
as
giannis can be mvp
and
there could be talk of anthony davis
coming for that crown
or
you know steph could be unanimous mvp a
couple of years back or kevin durant can
win finals in ep and beat lebron and
but at the end of the day we know who
the best player is
and some and and as as time goes on
sometimes people and voters in
particular some kind sometimes take him
for granted and then he
reminds us
that oh wait i'm still here this is
still
my title this is still my throne this is
still my belt i don't know if aaron is
still doing that but this is still my
belt until i give it up
i think roger's
excuse me i'm sorry well no no i'm not
no no no i don't see the reason i don't
like your analogy i don't like your
analogy at all
i like it for lebron james if you're
saying okay hey this is this is how
lebron james rolls
but if you're trying to say hey we're
talking about patrick mahomes right now
but everybody knows everybody know
that it's aaron rodgers uh league no no
it's not aaron rodgers league
it's not it hasn't been i've never i
never thought i didn't think he was you
never thought he was the best
quarterback in the league
i didn't i thought brady was
and brady is no longer the best
quarterback in the league i always
thought i always thought
i should have known i should have known
no no don't do that yeah don't do that
no i am i am doing it i am doing it yes
that's okay i can't do that go ahead and
do that because i like
good i'm glad you're doing it cause i
like when people like you
huh uh-huh uh-huh yeah you
you gonna sleep what do you mean you
people okay what do you mean don't think
about that yeah you people
i'm talking about you
i like when people like you
have these like
great arguments these these wonderful
arguments over over champagne and cheese
and you know you put the quarterback in
the museum if we're just
looking at the
uh just in a vacuum the thrower of the
football and just the poetry of the
spiral and they just put up they just do
a wonderful job wait with the pinky
finger right here there it is the pinky
finger off yeah right there there it is
does anyone have a teacup i don't have a
teacup unfortunately a saucer but yeah
does anyone throw the football as well
as aaron rodgers
that's part of the job that is not the
entire job so if you ask me have i seen
anybody throw a better ball than aaron
rodgers probably not
and he does some incredible things on
the field but quarterback is the it's a
multi-dimensional position so there are
people who don't throw the quarterbacks
don't throw the football so well but
they're great leaders and their teams
just miraculously win over and over and
they do so many things well
that's why tom brady do you want me to
let me okay okay do me a favor do me a
favor tom brady if if tom brady is the
okay we kind of we're talking about
playing the position but are playing the
position there's nothing tom brady
there's nothing tom brady there's
nothing tom brady does better than aaron
rodgers i didn't mean to reduce this to
a brady versus rogers thing
i don't know just lead a team not too
don't say it don't say it
leaders no no no no no lead a team
leader it's a leadership team a team i'm
taking away okay
i'm taking away the obvious
as if what's the obvious as if the
obvious doesn't matter the obvious is
not everything's obvious but i'm leaving
i'm putting that aside for now
oh i'm sorry i missed it we're going to
play this game we're going to play the
game
tom brady what's the obvious yeah are
you going to assign are you going to
assign a team accomplishment so
we're coming from different paradigms
here if you go go super bowls and play
off wins on me if that's what you're
going to pull out then okay then we're
talking now we're talking about team
accomplishments we're talking about
shout out
to an interview the most important
position
it's the most i'm not in the position
i'm not diminishing it you okay so it
matters
to the best thrower of the football as
if he hasn't thrown all of six
interceptions in the last couple of
years as if because if there's anything
that tom brady does at the position
it's not throwing a nice ball well
that's that's
you you're not we're getting off now
you're being disrespectful i don't like
your tone they use it too many big words
for me
watch your tone and it helped me with
the sale
no way wait a minute like no
nice ball
no he does he throws a great football
but i i don't know but i don't like okay
you don't like what i'm doing but i
don't like what you're doing either i
don't like okay hey he's so talented
and uh there's nothing he does there's
nothing that tom brady does better than
aaron rodgers okay that may be true if
you just go category by cat who's got a
better arm who's faster who can run and
pick up a first down all those things
matter
but
we're still talking about
putting all of it together for some goal
and the goal is what what is the goal
then the goal is a goal don't do that
but michael i i'm not talking about
physical just physical i'm saying even
playing quarterback accuracy decision
making you know managing the game
brady's not better than rogers at that
brady
listen uh and this is not i'm i'm not
doing a new england sports talk radio
thing that i know you're used to i don't
want you it's not what about new england
no no what about new england no i'm
saying that's wait no listen to me
listen to me i'm not doing
what it's gonna sound like i'm doing i'm
not saying that brady is is a result or
a product of the system in new england
that's not what i'm doing this is not a
he wouldn't be anything without
belichick that's not what i'm saying i
don't want you to misinterpret what i'm
about to say
i'm simply saying doc make it plain i am
no but but these
it would sound that way but that's not
what i'm suggesting i'm suggesting is
those six super bowls and those playoff
triumphs that you're talking about for
brady certainly give him the more
impressive resume than aaron rodgers i'm
simply saying that that's not
that's unfair to hold that aaron rodgers
did not have the luxury of being coached
by bill belichick or for many years of
defense like the patriots have put on
the field
in green bay that's all i'm i don't you
know me i don't like reducing
quarterback or any individual debates
which this is devolved into
into team accomplishments we talked
about this
that's where that's where i struggle
with this but you're doing the opposite
you're doing the opposite now and i
understand what you're saying okay
tom brady had some advantages
he had some advantages going for him you
know to be coached by
the greatest coach of all time and and
that and i'm not going to get into the
well would bill belichick be considered
the greatest coach of all time tom brady
was not there at the quarterback no no
i'm not going to get there because
that's just going down the rabbit hole
we'll never get out of it and there's no
answer yeah yeah yeah no and i would i
would never even take you there yeah but
you're almost holding tom brady's
advantages
i feel like are we talking about
football we're talking about something
else we're almost holding his privileges
against him that because he had bill
belichick
then you're almost taking points away
from him and it so it sounds like what
you're saying is if if you put aaron
rodgers in tom brady's position well
well what are you saying
that's not what i'm saying and i don't
like i don't like playing that game
either i only play that game either the
hypothetical nope their careers are what
they are i'm simply what i said was a
defense mechanism that was that was me
because
you see this got off the rails quite
honestly
no rails to get off the show
what i was looking at my point my point
and this is this is you you rejected the
premise which is fine let's just you
just reject the premise for me
aaron rodgers
is the best to ever play the position
okay
that's right now it's hard to hear he
may not be the most decorated
quarterback
that's obviously tom brady and i'm fine
with tom brady being you know having the
goat title six rings will get you that
and not to mention what he continues to
do what he's done and continues to do
not arguing against tom brady somehow in
terms of playing a position and all that
that entails
aaron rodgers is my guy he's not yours
and that's okay
so to get back to the point that set
this off i was simply saying that last
night was a y'all must have forgot
moment again i albeit against atlanta
y'all must have forgot moment for aaron
rodgers in the same way that every post
season or every so often
no matter how much we want to anoint the
next dude in the nba is the best player
in the nba lebron's like oh no i'm still
the guy you reject the idea that rogers
is that guy and that's fine if it's been
brady for you all this time that's fine
look it ain't hard to argue for tom
brady but for me right it's been aaron
rodgers and even this year
the conversation about mvp
he's clearly look he's clearly more
comfortable in matt lafleur's offense
robert tonyan robert tanyan the
co-leader in touchdown catches this year
said that he knew coming into the season
and this is gonna be a big year for
aaron rodgers a lot of it probably had
to do with him having a chip on his
shoulder because he picked his heir
apparent
in the first round you're in love out of
utah state so all i'm saying is like
aaron rodgers
if he had to serve notice i'm gonna do
what you did earlier serve notice to
people like you
that want to take the torch from him and
he's still here
he's still here he's still out here i
love it i love it man welcome back mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports